about 30 000 athletes are taking part in
the Boston Marathon today this year's
race marks a somber Milestone it has
been 10 years since two bombs exploded
near the Finish Line in a terror attack
three people were killed on that
horrific day and nearly 300 were wounded
two heroic officers involved in the
four-day Manhunt for the suspects also
died over the weekend the city honored
the victims and survivors in a ceremony
attended by hundreds of people including
First Responders Nancy Chen joins us
from near the Finish Line Nancy good
morning
good morning the runners are gathering
near the starting line right now before
making their way through the 26.2 mile
course and this year especially the race
will be celebrating the athletes but
also remembering the lives impacted by
what happened on that tragic day
[Applause]
as long-standing tradition of the 2013
Boston Marathon Drew crowds from all
over the world but in an instant
everything changed
when two bombs exploded near the Finish
Line eight-year-old Martin Richard 23
year old Luling Z and 29 year old
Crystal Campbell were killed I was
catapulted through the open doors of the
restaurant and I landed on the ground
and realized my foot was in a lot of
pain hundreds including Heather Abbott
were injured the damage stretched for
blocks this building was all caved in Ed
Davis was the Boston Police Commissioner
at the time the fact that it happened at
sort of a HomeTown event just sort of
brought this home to the whole nation
that these things can happen anywhere
the bombings had a lasting impact on
security practices Nationwide do you
think that other races around the
country changed their ways of policing
after this I know they did there was
enormous transfer of intelligence and
information so that our brothers in in
other cities would be able to to prepare
better
today the marathon still finishes in the
same spot the embodiment of Boston
Strong a mantra the city adopted after
the attack it's a reminder Abbott kept
in mind after her leg was amputated
below the knee
got it she learned to walk again and has
since graduated to snowboarding Running
part of the Marathon course and wearing
her beloved heels why was it important
for you to be able to walk in heels it
was just kind of part of who I was and
it was something I didn't want to have
to give up healing has also meant giving
back Abbott has helped more than a
hundred people get access to prosthetic
devices through her foundation she
started I've made an effort to not focus
on what I can't change and what I can't
change is what happened the day of the
Boston Marathon bombing so I try to look
forward and think about how I can change
the future and how I can make it better
Finish Line here later today to host her
foundation's annual watch party also
today there will be tens of thousands of
athletes but none will be wearing the
bib number 2013 which was not assigned
this year in remembrance of the tragedy
Nancy Chen live for us in Boston Nancy
thank you it is remarkable that it's
been 10 years that's what I was thinking
too I imagine I'm wondering how the
people of Boston feel today I imagine
every year about this time it triggers
all sorts of feelings for people but
good to see Heather Abbott up and about
but you can't help but remember the
people that lost their lives that day
that was so shocking we were on the
hashtag Boston Strong yes Boston Strong
really embodies it yeah she does all
right